well hi candy this is our third time
catching up in quarantine
yes how have you been i've been good you
know still stuck inside but you are
back to work on housewives which is kind
of wild in the middle of a global
pandemic you guys are able to film
walk me through what you're having to do
to make it work and make it happen
well let me say kudos to bravo and kudos
to truly original
um who produces our show they have been
going above
and beyond to make sure that everybody's
safe um
actually this morning i had to go get
tested
um every week the cast and crew were all
being tested um weekly as well as
they only allow only like very few
people
um within scene if either one of us
go out of town or do anything then we're
quarantined
um wow yeah
they care about our safety they care
about the safety of the crew and they've
been taking
every precaution okay
so does this affect what kind of things
you guys can do as a group in terms of
like
filming those group scenes and those
group events that we love to watch
yes i mean obviously we'll have to bring
down the number of people that we'll be
able to invite
and then you know we're because they are
following the rules of
not only our state of georgia but also
with the mayor
once we follow all the rules of city of
atlanta
so it's just you know it limits where
you can go
it limits how many people i could have
come through because you know me i'll
have an event there's like tons of
people
right i can't do that anymore but
as far as you know the ladies you know
our close family members
um you know they're testing some of our
family and um
significant others or whatever as well
um
so everybody there will feel safe and be
safe we saw you guys hanging out with
eva on instagram do you think she'll
still kind of have a presence
in this you know i was talking to her
about that yesterday
i was saying like people still want her
to be
you know amongst the group even if you
know she's decided not to be
you know a regular part of the show so
you know obviously that's always up to
her as of now she's like no
you know whatever but i hope she changes
her mind
because at the end of the day we do have
a genuine
relationship that wasn't for camera
anything she invited us over her
house because she cooked and then she
invited kenya and
cynthia and the cool thing is like you
know what people are unfortunately not
gonna get to see is that her and kenya
are like really really cool
super tight now and wow yeah like their
kids
are like they love each other and like
if you would have saw
the way that little mikey lit up when
brooklyn came in the door cute
it was too cute there was a report that
came out that nene is out and you got
two new girls on atlanta can you tell me
anything
i just started taping so i'm not
sure who's in and who's out they don't
let us know normally typically the way
it works is in the beginning of taping
you know i start really you know we just
see more of my own
personal life and story and eventually
you trickling in
scenes with other people you know what i
mean
and until we have like you know
something where everybody's supposed to
be there i'm not sure who everybody is
okay got it so you have not filmed with
nina yet
you can't try to get me in trouble i'm
just doing my job i'm just doing my job
i don't know what nene's doing i don't
know well the world has changed a lot
since even the reunion tape we are right
now
experiencing a reckoning on racism do
you think that's going to
impact what kind of conversations you
guys are having as a group and
want to bring to tv you know it's a
reality show
which means you have to keep it real and
we have to you know talk about what's
really happening around us
right now a lot of us are involved in
what's going on in the world and trying
to bring equality
clearly portia just got arrested
last week for you know protesting so
i mean obviously we're gonna have to
talk about a lot of those things and
you know we're just in the beginning so
we'll see as it goes but
just like everything that's happening in
our lives we we talk about it so it's
definitely gonna be discussed
i love what portia is doing right now i
love the fact that she's stepping up
especially in her grandfather's
footsteps i mean her grandfather was on
the forefront of the civil rights
movement
so it's it's a wonderful thing to see
her step up in the way that she's been
stepping up and
you know putting her own freedom
on the line um for what she believes in
you know
taking a little shift here you on the
atlanta reunion
let it slip that an old lady gang tv
show is coming
[Laughter]
nene i know you were on instagram live
and you were kind of alluding to
all of candy's spin-offs no i was not
no no i was not who was you talking
about then it doesn't matter what can
you tell me about this
anything have that conversation didn't i
i was surprised they let that error to
be honest with you because normally we
say something that we're not supposed to
say
normally they cut it out well okay um
it's a restaurant
obviously and unlike with housewives
we have more interaction with people and
it's in the city of atlanta so
right now we're on hold
until things die down with the numbers
of covet cases
can you give me a hint of what the setup
is like would you compare it to
vanderpump rules would you compare it to
anything that's on the air
i'm not allowed to tell you
i've already said too much you're about
to get me in trouble
okay okay we're gonna get more mama
joyce on tv though right
oh for sure the cool thing is
there are many very extremely
uh funny characters that will be a part
of olg
so i'm excited to see it they will be
even more entertaining than you can even
imagine but we're not here to talk about
that
we are here to talk about candy burris
the actress
what does it mean to you to be
identified that way because you've been
a singer and tv personality for so long
and now to you've acted but i feel like
the shy
is the first really big job well it is
um this is my first time having a
reoccurring role on
any you know tv series ever so this is
for me this is like a really big deal
we've met rosalind she is quite
something
yeah she where's otis he's busy
do you have an appointment i don't need
an appointment i'm his wife
this much talked about sex scene that we
heard about on atlanta
has aired yes it did
when i got there i honestly i thought
that i was gonna have to do
more as far as nudity or something was
concerned
it turned out that i didn't have to bear
as much
as i thought that i would but it still
was a little racy and
you know you know you got to give
something for the people that's what i
said well i feel like part of the
conversation on housewives was that
maybe todd was gonna
feel a certain way about this scene i'm
not totally
into the sex scenes but
well i'm thankful that you're trying to
be understanding
okay you're being such a great husband
so did he watch and how did he feel he
was much better
after it aired we were much better now
and everything's okay
he said he doesn't know how he would
feel about me
doing it doing another you know sex
scene or whatever
in the future but for now he's okay so
what is still to come for rosalind on
this season of the shot
okay so roslyn is she's a little feisty
a little feisty woman you know what i
mean um overall duda who is her husband
on the show
they have a love-hate relationship so
it's like does she really want him to
win
or does she not want him to win that's
where you know it may be going there
and you know becoming this woman you
know those are the questions that i have
to ask myself when i'm trying to figure
out
okay how am i playing this you know you
do how how much do i love him do i
really want him to win or do i not want
him to win
you know do i really have his back or do
i not have his back and so
um you know we see that as time
progresses so is acting something you
had always been interested in or was it
something that you picked up an interest
in as you got older what's the story
there
i've always had an interest in acting um
the thing is
um as a kid i went to the tr i went to
tri-cities high school of visual and
performing arts
i was in the performing arts program for
drama a lot of people don't know
know that the love of acting has always
been there for me i just never really
pursued it like i wanted to
you know my younger years but you know
now i just said you know what
um in the last i would say five or six
years i've really been i'm pushing to
do more than doing lots of auditions i
had a lot of smaller roles here and
there on
different things but this is the first
time that i've actually had the
opportunity
to have a recurring role which is super
exciting so what have you gone out for
are there any projects that you like you
almost had that we would know about
yes but i don't want to tell you
[Laughter]
give me one uh i can't i don't want to
name the show but there's a show
actually that i love
the producers all the um the casting
everybody had
you know they said i had the part you
know they were like oh we love her she
has the part blah blah blah the network
did not
approve me because i was on a reality
show wow
i was devastated i'm still a suit i'm a
super fan of the show
the show is like great to me but it
makes me sad it used to make me sad
every time i watched
that particular role that i was supposed
to be like that could have been me
i'm gonna be paying attention to what
you post about and what you tweet about
that you're watching to figure this out
posted about it i never tweeted about it
um it was just something you know only
my close group of friends know about
normally i keep things to myself until i
know i have it
the other day i was with some friends
and i was like oh guess what
and then i had to go back and tell them
all that what happened i was so sad
well it didn't kill your drive or your
dream so are you hungry now to get
out there and do more projects what's
your dream role
i would love something that i really
could show
just every emotion i guess like a show
like this is us
or you know any you know any show that
is just like really takes you
to you know to where you're in tears or
to where you just laugh your heart out
you know one of those type of roles all
right we'll put it out there in the
universe and hopefully it comes back
your way
you